hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in his review of the work the two
ages in the section devoted to the
present age providing a critique of the
modern period that he is living in
perhaps with some implications for our
own times sir kard is going to talk
about a number of different ways in
which a passionate
disjunction between two polarities has
been analed or negated and the effects
that this has for the individual person
and society and this is going to be
connected with what he calls the public
now he he goes through a number of these
but the one which he begins with and
talks about at greatest length is the
distinction between being silent and
speaking and what ends up coming in its
place but before we jump into that
there's a little bit of background that
we should re-elaborate just to remind
ourselves about why this really matters
so he tells us
that in the present age what we end up
seeing uh is reflection uh devoid of
passion and gaining in extensity what it
loses in intensity and he says the
existential expression of nullifying the
principle of contradiction now this
sounds very very abstract what is the
principle of contradiction it's saying
it's a logical principle that we get out
of uh logic and metaphysics but we can
also apply to moral matters something
cannot be and not be in the same way at
the same
time and this how does it fit into
ethical or moral matters or religious
matters for kard well we
decide between two Alternatives that are
opposed to each other or maybe we don't
so he says the ex existential expression
of nullifying the principle of
contradiction is to be in contradiction
to
oneself and he talks about the creative
omnipotence for each of us implicit in
the passion of absolute djunction that
leads an individual resolutely to make
up his mind this is something that
otherwise was available for us uh is
transformed into the extensity of
prudence and Reflection by knowing and
being everything possible to be in
contradiction to oneself that is to be
nothing at all and he says the principle
of contradiction strengthens the
individual and faithfulness TOS you make
a decision and now you're stuck with it
right but you have actually decided you
have committed what if you don't commit
What If instead you nullify this
disjunction so he says that um you're
going to wind up in contradiction to
yourself and he talks about
chattering so he says well what is it to
chatter it is the
analment of the
passionate disjunction between being
silent and speaking now notice this
isn't just a logical disjunction this is
a passionate disjunction it has to do
with our affectivity it has to do with
our will it has to do with what we
commit ourselves to and this is the
person who in a certain sense tries to
have it all rather than saying well I
got to pick this or this and in trying
to have it all they wind up
losing both sides and slipping into
something different so we can represent
this by putting being silent on one side
of this passionate disjunction putting
speaking on the other side of this
passionate disjunction and talk about
the Resolute making up of one's mind now
of course it's not as if you commit
yourself most people to only speaking or
only being silent what what ends up
happening is you alternate between the
two of them you fall silent for a while
and then you just side there's something
actually worth saying so you say it and
then you go back into silence again and
you oscillate between the two and as
kard is going to tell us you need the
silence in order to actually speak so he
says only the person who can remain
essentially silent can speak essentially
so this shows us that we can speak
essentially we can also use our faculty
of speech in non-essential ways that's
part of what chattering is going to be
but notice the next line after that can
act
essentially so under speaking we should
understand not simply speaking but also
acting and as he's going to talk about
it a little bit later producing
producing things through linguistic
expressions or perhaps other modes of
expression as as well and it tells us
that um silence is inwardness so this is
quite important we bring something out
of ourselves that is there in that
silence and that is what we speak I mean
we can speak about other things as well
all of our speaking doesn't have to be
calling our feelings or thoughts out of
great inwardness it can have reference
to the world it can have reference to
other people but there has to be silence
or else it's not truly speaking and he
says chattering gets ahead of essential
speaking giving utterance to reflection
has a weakening effect on action by
getting ahead of it and you know think
in our own time about people who can't
just say what they're going to say
they've got to do a little Preamble
first and they've got to have all sorts
of little affectations and they've got
to have provisos and you know then they
need to uh you know ask people what what
do you think about that and and get
everybody else involved in the act of
taking a stand through speaking and this
doesn't just have to be speaking this
could be in writing this could be in
social media this could be in a myriad
of different ways so he says that the
person who can speak essentially because
he's able to keep keep silent will not
have a profusion of things to speak
about but one thing only the thing that
they actually need to talk about
whatever it happens to be at that time
and he will find time to speak and to
keep
silent now this is where it gets really
interesting
temporally if you really only have one
thing that you need to say you don't
need to talk all the time you said it
now you can allow silence and let other
people digest what it is that you've
said think about it I mean you could
repeat yourself you could talk about
other aspects of the thing that you've
just set out there but at a certain
point you get to shut up and you don't
have to keep going on and on instead
talkativeness he says gains in extensity
and he'll also talk about this as
externality in just a bit as well it
shatter matters about anything and
everything and continues
incessantly the person who has to talk
just to talk you've encountered many
people like that perhaps you've yourself
fallen into that at one point or another
through nervousness through
embarrassment through not wanting there
to be empty space and time and you know
a a lack of language you could say
by contrast he says when individuals are
not turned inward in quiet contentment
that's what's possible in silence in
inner satisfaction and religious
sensitiveness but in a relation of
reflection are oriented to
externalities things outside of
themselves and to each other when no
important event ties the loose loose
threads together in the unan unanimity
of a CR crucial change then shattering
be begins people talk and they chatter
when there's really nothing else going
on and so he contrast this against a
passionate age so he's not saying that
this is the case for everybody all the
time even in modernity it's possible to
have a present age of reflection it's
also possible to have a preceding
passionate age and perhaps we could even
move back into another passionate
age so he says ch in has a great deal to
chatter
about by contrast when an important
event has taken place after it's
happened you fall silent you don't need
after you've spoken to keep on
chattering about this it says chattering
dreads the moment of silence and now
notice this
phrase which would reveal the emptiness
the emptiness of not having anything to
truly value or even to talk about so it
talks about everything and he he gives
Prime examples I'm going to jump ahead a
little bit here he talks about the novel
itself um the substance is mere Trifles
but they're always about specific people
mentioned by name whose trivial lives
are interesting because of their names
one who Chatters presumably does chatter
about something since the aim is to find
something to chatter about but this
something is not something in the sense
of ideality a term that he's using here
now he doesn't mean ideality in the
sense of abstraction from
life he doesn't mean ideality either in
the sense of some sort of far off
Paradigm or pattern this isn't platonic
ideality this is thinking about what is
great what matters what has value
in the real world that we are living in
and so coming back to the text he says
the law manifest in Poetic
production is identical on a smaller
scale with the law of for the life of
every person in social intercourse and
education so there is a analogy being
drawn there poetic production produces
books or plays or music or we can go on
and on and on it might even produce
important things happening in human
Affairs and then we have our own smaller
individual scale every person in social
intercourse and
education so he says anyone who
experiences anything primitively also
experiences in
ideality the possibilities of the same
thing and the possibility of the
opposite these possibilities are his
legit imate literary property his own
personal actuality is not his speaking
and his producing notice how these go
hand in hand are as he's going to tell
us going to correspond to his silence
the Supreme Mark of that silence will be
that the ideality contains the
qualitatively opposite possibility so we
have opposites in two different ways
here you could say we have an opposite
of content
right the what it is and its opposite
but we also have opposites being
silent and giving articulation speaking
bringing
this into being in front of us being
able to talk about the Opposites and
kard will actually give us an example
here as
well he tells us that um e ideality is
the equilibrium of
opposites someone who has been motivated
to creativity by unhappiness which is
often the case isn't it if he is
genuinely devoted to ideality will be
equally inclined to write about
happiness and about
unhappiness but silence the brackets he
puts around his own personality is
precisely the condition for gaining
ideality so you know sometimes people
say well you've got to write what you
know well yes and no kard is saying
don't do a tell all don't make yourself
the subject that you're throwing out
there and then talk and all sorts of
trivialities about yourself and get into
nervous neuroticism about whether you're
revealing yourself enough for any I mean
that's reflection that's check battering
that's another word that he's going to
use
gisness speak go ahead and speak forth
you can mention yourself you can talk
about your own place and things but
don't reveal everything or feel like you
have to fill the page or fill the air or
whatever else you know fill the Twitter
or Facebook thread with lots and lots of
stuff so he he goes on and he says that
um what holds true in the large picture
um because it appears most clearly there
also holds true in a lesser way in the
smaller picture silence is the condition
for cultured conversation between human
being and human being the more a person
has ideality and ideas in silence this
oscillation between being silent and
speaking the more they will be able even
in Daily associations to reproduce his
daily life and that of others in such a
way that he seems to be speaking only at
a distance about specific
matters the less ideality the more we're
chattering the more the conversation
becomes a trivial rattling and name
dropping and again kard is writing this
nearly two centuries ago but doesn't
this seem as if it could be right right
out of the present for many of the
conversations we're involved in he says
references to persons with absolutely
reliable private information on what
this one and that one mentioned by name
have said a gelous confiding of what he
himself wants or does not want his plans
what he would have said on that occasion
what girl he is courting why he is not
still ready to get married
Etc in order to have cultured
conversation kard tells us inwardness
being silent is actually necessary you
need to leave space
pauses so that the speaking has
something to contrast
with he goes on uh a little bit further
and says this really interesting thought
experiment suppose a law were passed and
could be maintained that did not forbid
people to speak but merely ordered that
everything spoken about had to be spoken
about as if it had happened 50 years ago
then all the chatterers would be sunk
why because they chatter about stuff
that doesn't really matter and they
chatter about it in a way that makes it
sound as if it matters but reveals that
it doesn't matter the many trivialities
of our opinions our judgments our
reactions if we were going to see them
at a distance of 50 years
would they be valuable would they be
worth speaking about or would we keep
silent about
them we probably unless we're congenital
chatterers people who no longer know how
to be silent or speak perhaps because of
the age they live in perhaps because
they've never encountered other people
who know how to be silent or speak or
because they couldn't recognize them if
we're like that then we'll just keep on
talking and talking and talking think
about all these shows that we fill our
streaming content with about things that
are taken very very seriously by the
people in the shows but are just
complete wastes of our time or the tiffs
that people get into over the topic of
the day whether it's on you know the
right or left or Center or pick you know
some other orientation there's so much
that people chatter
about that if we applied this this test
this thought experiment perhaps people
wouldn't care about it anymore right so
he says by this
chattering the disjunction between what
is private and what is public is also
nullified in a private public gness
which is just about what the public is
so he's telling us something really
important here about this key idea that
he has of the
public what in other places he's called
The Crowd eded by the Press so he tells
us the public is public opinion that is
interested in what is utterly private
something no one would dare present at a
meeting something that no one would be
able to speak about something even
gossips would scarcely admit to having
chattered about can very well be put in
writing for the public and be known by
the public as the public and again think
about so many different television shows
with people who appear to be important
but are ultimately just trivialities
mere placeholders you know what is their
relationship to each other did they go
on a date with each other why are they
mad at each other you know what about
this thing over here and this thing over
here and who went to what
party that's just chatter from KAG
guard's perspective and if we want to
have a more full Rich meaningful
authentic life we probably need to
figure out if we are chattering and
perhaps chatterers how to get back to
this passionate disjunction between
being
silent and
speaking